Videoma sponsor olduğu için 6365'e teşekkür ederiz.
İzlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim.
Altyum 365
PCB tasarımı, MCAT veri yönetimi ve ekip çalışmasını birleştiren elektronik ürün tasarım platformudur.
Kurmak paya yapılandırmak için ekstra bir ücret ya da lisans almanıza gerek yok.
Altyum Designer içinden direkt bağlanabilirsiniz.
Ayrıca müşterileriniz ya da ekip arkadaşlarınız internet bağlantısı ve internet tarayıcısı üzerinden çalışmalarınızı görüntüleyebilir ve bunlarla ilgili yorum ve değerlendirmelerde bulunabilir.
Açıklamalar kısmında bulunan linki kullanarak Altyum Designer yazılımının ücretsiz versiyonunu bilgisayarınıza indirip kurarak denemeye hemen başlayabilirsiniz.
Altyazı M.K.